je m'appelle guilbart j'ai vécu pendant
trois ans dans les camps de
concentration chinois et le 21 août 2019
j'ai pu retrouver ma famille en france
[Musique]
man has had
je n'ai jamais fait d'activité contre le
régime chinois c'est pourquoi je n'ai
rien soupçonner quand j'ai reçu l'appel
de mon entreprise
lors du premier interrogatoire ils m'ont
montré une photo de ma fille prise à une
manifestation avec un drapeau du
turkestan oriental
ils ont confisqué mon passeport et mon
envoyé en maison d'arrêt
mais à mon arrivée ils m'ont mis les
chaînes aux pieds nous enfermer dans une
cellule
nous étions vingt à trente femmes serré
dans une cellule
nous avions toutes les pieds enchaînés
il faisait très froid
nous étions à famars avant d'aller à un
interrogatoire et nous menottes les
mains et en plus ils nous mettent une
cagoule noire sur la tête sur un mur de
la cellule il ya le règlement intérieur
qu'on doit apprendre par coeur
nous sommes interrogés au hasard et si
on échoue n'est puni
chaque nuit nous devons tenir la garde à
tour de rôle dans la cellule nous avons
un sommeil médiocre
dans les camps nous avons une heure de
cours à 6 nous avions des cours
d'histoire de droit de chinois avant le
shaq cours nous devions remercier la
grande chine
le parti communiste ainsi que si jean
ping après chaque cours
nous devons souhaiter nos voeux à ces
trois entités de plus nous avons des
évaluations chaque semaine et nous
devons également apprendre et chanter
devant tout le monde une chanson rouge
toutes les semaines nous étions vacciner
contre la grippe deux fois par an
quelques jours avant nous donnions notre
consentement écrit et si l'on voulait
pas et nous faisait la leçon et nous
forcer à recevoir le vaccin
j'ai vu beaucoup de jeunes filles
s'inquiéter de leur avenir car elle
n'avait plus la règle elle était
inquiète car elle voulait se marier
avoir des enfants mais je n'ai jamais su
si ces vaccins étaient réellement contre
la grippe
j'ai appris plus tard l'existence des
stérilisations forcées à mon retour en
france
pouvons pas communiquer en ouigours
aucune de nos traditions n'est respectée
selon moi le gouvernement chinois
essaient de nous assimiler leurs propres
cultures et traditions
ils essaient de nous faire disparaître
nous avons toute une autre procès ils
ont réaménagé une simple salle de
réunion une salle le procès les
policiers jouer le rôle des juges
ils n'ont pas de robe de juge mais de
simples d'uniformes policiers soit cela
hamas sarthe la santé chaque procès ne
faisait même pas dix minutes quand voir
tron mais d'autres bars matin les
détenus ils sont amenés par groupes de
quatre il m'accuse d'avoir un mari
activistes et une fille qui va des
manifestations séparatistes et à la fin
je suis condamnée à 7 ans d'enfermement
quelques jeunes
j'ai trouvé ça drôle car je ne savais
pas s'il me jugez moi marie ou ma fille
a été condamnée à sept ans sans avoir
rien fait apparu extrêmement ridicule
même si j'ai retrouvé ma vie d'avant mon
état de santé n'est plus même ma vue a
fortement baissé
j'ai des soucis de santé des douleurs au
dos aux articulations
ma mémoire se détériore également stable
à base de plus j'ai peur et j'ai peur
facilement par exemple comme je me
promène je sursaute
si quelqu'un passe très vite près de moi
même si je n'avais rien fait ils m'ont
quand même enfermée pendant trois ans et
détruit ma liberté
au début j'ai eu peur qu'il arrive un
malheur à ma famille si je publier ce
livre à mon nom j'ai quand même décidé
de lever l'anonymat
mais je n'ai jamais cessé de m'inquiéter
pour ma famille
je pense que la chine mène un génocide
culturel contre les ouïghours
tornos patane parce que nous ne pouvons
pas du tout par les ouïghours dans les
camps la langue ouïgoure est de moins en
moins enseigné dans les écoles et en
plus la chine plébiscite des mariages
entre ouïghours et han un couple
interethniques reçoit 150 mille yuan de
l'état qui fait une réelle propagande de
ce type de mariage
je pense que cela suffit pour dire qu'il
s'agit d'un réel génocide contre notre
ethnie